well if you've been doing all that
shopping for black friday and then small
business saturday and then cyber monday
hey you know what it's time to spread a
little bit of that love to all the
organizations that really depend on you
to help others so last year for giving
to tuesday well more than two and a half
billion dollars was donated nationwide
in just 24 hours the question is of
course how can you help today hector
mejia is live this morning rainbow and
oaky to profile hearts alive village a
nonprofit we've showcased here on the
program before hector good morning to
you
good morning guys and i want you guys to
say hello to damien check out damien
right here this is cheryl cheryl with
hearts of live village i don't know you
guys had bears up for adoption yeah you
know whoever needs help we help the
perfect guard dog right yes absolutely
aren't you terrified right now
tell us about damon and his backstory um
so damian and his brother houdini their
dad actually went into the hospital and
was in there for a couple of weeks
neighbor was coming over and taking care
of them unfortunately dad passed away
so
they are looking for a new home together
they've already lost their daddy we
don't want them to lose each other so
today on giving tuesday how can people
help out dogs like damien
donate
obviously uh you know giving tuesday is
the biggest donation year day of the
year um and we need the support so that
we can save animals like damian tell us
about the programs you guys offer to the
community um so a lot of our focus is
keeping pets in their original homes
whenever possible
we do that through our pet food bank and
we also have a low cost clinic
so that people can afford veterinary
care and don't have to surrender their
animals just because they're sick
nice thank you and so going back to
damian i mean at first glance he's kind
of intimidating he's a large dog but
he's just a sleeper he just wants to nap
all day he does he's a cuddle bug so i
think that's what we're gonna do after
this it's just a good snuggle and you
guys we tried to get him up a few
minutes ago and he just he just wouldn't
he just wants to stay on the floor he is
good he's he's taking his morning siesta
let's see if he gets up let's see all
right
come on all right so lastly uh tell us
more
he just wants to stay there
he just needs his morning coffee check
him out and doesn't he look like a bear
look at how large he is he is massive
yeah damien is uh showing off the goods
what damian wants damien i feel like is
what's going on here
thank you you know the phones are
ringing maybe someone's watching and
they want to adopt him
so if you want to adopt him go to hearts
alive village.org
go to adoptables and you can actually
apply directly on the website awesome
there you go guys reporting live hector
mejia and mr damon here damien the
napper back to you guys
so many great non-profits around the
valley that need a lot of help hearts
alive villa is just one of uh one of
many oh gosh i hope there's somebody out
there who can take him in his sibling
houdini home what a cutie pie oh he's
loving his life thanks hector and there
are so many local nonprofits taking part
in giving tuesday here's a look is just
some of them and you can find a link we
put it all on our website
eightnewsnow.com that way you can find
one that really speaks to you
damian a little too relaxed here on the
morning show